Thank you. Thanks for the
invitation to say come here. Um,
so I'll just talk to you
about the company's soapbox.
Loves to start with. Um,
we do children's speech
recognition technologies,
so that way.
Um,
so 2017 and 2018, we're like
huge years for voice assistance.
Um, across the world. The stars,
you can say 2015 when Amazon first release
the Alexis to the u s market and it's
taking a long time to get to this
side of the ocean. I said the same.
We've seen newcomers come on, but
more recently we know that, you know,
Google came on the heels
of Alexa apple this year,
uh, Facebook or talking about a device. By
the end of this year, they postponed up.
It's still a flexes coming out.
Um,
what's changed over the
last couple of years,
people are beginning to see the
utility of voice assistance, um,
a couple of years ago, um, you know,
speech recognition technologies,
we're probably working
on the 80% accuracy. Um,
so it meant they're still
quite frustrating to work with,
so people begin just to kind of doubted
we would ever really take off. But, um,
myself has been working in this area for
over 20 years and was kind of a case of
one steep learning, a vast volumes of data
and gps and all that came together. Um,
we could see the scale of us and
we could see the utility. Um,
I spent some time working
on IBM a long time ago. Um,
IBM research and back in 2004 we actually
saw a demo of the voice assistant.
But how,
you know,
the idea of somebody would be driving
in the car and they want to go to a
restaurant and the car would ask them,
you know,
the system would ask about what kind of
restaurant did you want to go to and get
some feedback on realtime feedback
on traffic and direct them to or go.
And it was 2003,
I think it has an a four.
So when I was there and I was research
assistant at the time that was imminent,
you know, this is what they were
going to put in cars and you know,
are stunned with a year or two and it's
actually taken this long to get real
voice assistants. I've really utility
and what's happened there, it's accuracy.
It's actually less frustrating.
So if you tried it a few years
ago was extremely frustrated.
They've got it wrong too often.
That's all it wasn't though.
It's getting them all the time,
but just too often.
That was a frustration experience and
that's what's changed in recent years.
But it's not just the voice assistance,
right?
It's there's any number of these companies
that are doing seriously doing speech
recognition technologies.
Right.
So I think tech crunch things late 2016
said there was like 29 companies in the
u s and learned in speech recognition
stuff. Not Counting in Asia.
It's not Canton,
European companies and snuff cans
and what's happening in 2018 right.
That was a year and a half ago.
But all these companies are
doing spectacular things.
So you're seeing voice assistance.
You know, when we had the first,
it was Siri and it was okay Google
and it was on your personal device.
They've taken a leap from the
personal device into the home.
And that's really interesting from my
perspective what's happened there. Um,
you know,
it's something we all have to pay close
attention to because it's just the tip
of the iceberg. I mean, people think, wow,
look at this amazing technology and
what's going to do for fun. You know,
to my mind, this is just the
start. It would be, you know,
even from our own experiences
of the last couple of years,
it'd be on your fridge,
your TV,
your car to be in a vending machine.
It's,
it's not just that it's a voice assistant.
It's actually going to be the
stage that speech technology,
voice technology has gone to replace
keyboards, touch a swipe gesture,
all of these things because
it's the natural interface
is how humans communicate.
So it only makes sense that of
technology can do it. So that stage,
why are we all still typing and clicking?
And you know,
we have to do that because of the
technology wasn't there to begin with. Um,
but what happens with that is when we
actually start replacing interface and the
voice becomes the norm,
you have to recognize the fact that you've
put it in the home and children will
use it. I'm industrial city given
it's not about what you want,
whatever you bought, you volunteer to take
something and put it into the home. Um,
it will engage children because
number one, it's fun. You know what?
Child isn't going to try
it the moment you do it,
they're going to do it
immediately after you. Um, what?
It's also easier for them than clicking
and typing cause la times or even free
illiterate or they're
struggling with dexterity.
It's actually a great interface for
children as well. And it's already there.
So the question is how do we handle it?
What's the utility?
So in every place that you could see
an adult using speech technology,
other than dictating
your business documents,
you're going to see that
children one years or two lights,
especially when you take it
outside of the office environment,
you're going to see that they're using it.
Other application areas we see
for it in particular is, um,
and what we started with actually soapbox
loves originally our mission statement
back in 2013 was more around education.
So if you think about how
a child learns to read, uh,
the most effective way a child learns
Sweden's one to one oral guided reading,
right? So that means, um, and helpful
adult working alongside a child.
And if you think, do you ever watch, uh,
a parent or a teacher teaching
a child to read? They listen.
They correct their prompt thing,
courage in the assess, right?
And it's that one to one that actually
it's a bit more than 10 minutes of the
day, but between 10 and 20 minutes a day
is recommended for a child to get to, um,
you know, to accelerate the truant
decent level. But in the world today,
literacy levels of stagnated over the
last 10 years in the u s 60% of kids at
age eight are not reading at a proficient
level and a child that doesn't read at
a proficient level at age eight, it's a
key indicator of their future success.
It's quite a key moment because that's
when most kids stuck learning to read and
start reading to learn.
So if you are struggling before that,
it's going to get harder and harder
to catch up with your peers. Um,
so one of the ways when we'd been looking
at this over the years is that if you
know the one way to increase the region,
it's one to one engagement.
You're not suddenly going to find funding
to stick more teachers into homes or
suddenly free your parents' time or get
private tutors or you can do is provide
a scalable cost effective solution that
speech technology that can actually act
as that helpful adult listening.
As a child reads the cat sat on the mat,
I cracked in prompting and assessing and
do that personalized learning journey
for them.
And the same goes for English language
learning or other language learning
depending on where you're
from. Um, the same thing.
It's guided or reasons
for personalized learning.
Personalized education is a
huge area in the world today,
but actually nobody has a solution really
for reading and they can do it from us
and science and junk food for the cat.
Do it for reading.
And you can't do it
from language learning.
And the statistics if I for
reading is actually masking a big,
much worse problem for a
disadvantaged children,
an immigrant children because those
kids are actually two years behind their
peers, um, in in studies
piece of studies. Um,
so there are the kids who actually want
me would benefit the most from these
type of technologies
that are cost effective.
They're scalable and all their required
as a cheap android device on it means to,
um, I mean it's one of those devices. So
that's one of the areas we're focused on.
Um,
another area that we've had a huge amount
of inbound interest in social robots.
It's called a robotics for fun and
entertainment. Get them to move front,
but also social route robots engaged,
um,
engage them in an educational way
or lots of times kids with learning
difficulties as well. Um, but again,
voice technology to all
to have that meaningful
interaction is really important.
Um, the more fun stuff like in Vr, which
also can, you know, can be education,
but what else can we just
pure entertainment and then
just pure gaming as well.
I mean, where you see voice
technology like for adults coming in,
the solutions for children's while.
Makes Sense.
So I'm just going to show you a quick
video here on this is one of the reasons
why are focusing the last five
years have been somewhat different.
Um, I'll just play this for you
and you'll understand what I mean.
So this is when you stick
a voice assistant into the
hall and what can go wrong?
I can't find the song to good Tucker
outreach,
Huh?
Laughter.
Oh
Wow.
Mommy,
can you talk to play wheel?
You want to hear a station for porn
detected porno region, the hot chick,
amateur girl pussy. Anal dildo wrinkles.
So it's a funny, cute video, right?
But it actually indicates kind of more
serious problems they have with when you
put advice into Tom, where's the filter?
All right. You know, you, you can say I,
it's not designed for, not marked as a
kid, but I didn't put it there for kids,
but kids are going to use them then
we have to face up to that. Right?
So some of the folks of our company over
the last five years has been accuracy
for children's voices.
Okay.
Systems environments that are
fit for kids on data privacy.
So accuracy. Why his speech
technology difficult for children. Um,
most systems be built with adult
data modeling, adult behaviors,
physical and otherwise. Um, but children
are physically different from adults,
particularly in the focal trough there.
Tenor and shorter.
So where men's voices might be lower,
women's are overlapping but higher.
And then that's a tween teenager is that
kind of overlap on women as they get
younger,
the physical differences get further
and further away from an adult.
And that happens right? At Age 12, on
the younger you get, the more different,
it is not actually just visiting causes
confusion about what actually has been
said. The behavior is on the other hand
are just wildly different kids or was the
unpredictable, the, you know, they
stole her, they repeat the shape,
they whisper this thing like,
you know, you know, they um,
they punctuate their words and no fluff
more than that done. They're more fluent,
older, uh, siblings and
other children and adults.
That actually is a real problem for end
point detection if anybody's ever worked
in that way. Um, you know, because
they don't just behave the same way.
And what you end up doing is seeing
that a system that has been designed for
adults are using out of date
or modeling of behavior.
It's extremely frustrating for a
child and the younger the child,
the more frustrating it is,
has a negative effect on brand in some
ways because people associate that
technology.
They don't,
a lot of people don't process the fact
that it's just different voices different.
They just think the public doesn't
working very well. And, you know,
I had a pain in my head for my
youngest son asking me to, uh,
can you ask Alexa? And when
we got our first store, you
know, for the first one. So
what we've done is spend the last five
years concentrating on, excuse me,
mmm.
Pacific Child Pacific models.
So what we did was look at data from a
children's young was for but the day.
So it was a conversational
prompted red, um, spontaneous,
um, and build models that were
very specific to young children.
We spend time studying
how children converse, had
children's speak to technology,
um, the variants and not, and how
do you cope with that? And Heidi,
you build the system specifically
designed for children. Uh,
we collected data in real
world environments. So
that meant, you know, when,
you know where children are and they're
in their homes and their schools and um,
you too. So you can actually understand
the children don't, um, you know,
they don't use technology in
a quiet lab like environment.
And if you build your speech technology
on data, that's my techs in our lab,
like a quiet environment. It will only
ever work in those environments. Um,
so to move away from that,
you have to be able to get away from the
headset and likes and get away from all
that.
And then I let children just be natural
with how they want to interact with the
technology.
And then it's more up to us to change
our technology and then the charge to
change their behaviors because you won't
find a five year olds go modify their
behavior as much as an adult will.
And that's how we've been
getting away with a lot with um,
voice technology and the assistance that
we know that adult sometimes modify the
behavior is to get a response. Children
are less, uh, less likely to do so.
So another issue is, is the system fit for
children? Um, and are they appropriate?
So two examples.
I can give you this as um,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
the press secretary for
Donald Trump recently tweeted
that I, her three year old,
um, ordered, uh, Batman on
Amazon. Alexa be compelled,
she showed it is trying to show to us up,
man up that device three times and
suddenly got ordered. So, you know,
I call that somewhat in question
that the Ui works like that,
but it kind of did flag up an issue.
If a child uses a device that has
access to purchasing power, why is that?
I linked to do it.
That's not appropriate behavior for a
child interacting with a device in the
home. Similarly, my daughter
was, she's eight now.
Um, she was using my phone and,
and you know, I had it locked,
but she got onto the Siri thing and she
was just, you know, sitting with me and,
and using Siri task questions. Siri
misunderstood the, he said, bitch,
she didn't, but my, my daughter was
shocked and showed me the phone,
what the word is printed to
screen. And Syria replied with, oh,
there's no need for that,
which is very amusing and nice,
but why didn't it recognize that as a
child voice and not print them to screen?
Um, so I think, you know, when you
consider the fact of the, you know,
the first video with the
child's potentially accessing
inappropriate material,
inappropriate lyrics, songs, uh,
purchasing power, um, you know,
inappropriate words at potentially active
access in your contact list and doing
video calling or wherever.
What needs to happen is when we've
been working with clients to do is to
recognize that the point
of the voice interaction,
whether it's a child or whether
it's an adult and act appropriately,
route the child to a
different environments, safe
child, safe environment,
enough to the world wide web where they
can do an open search and such things.
And that's important when we put these
devices in their homes and in the cars
and then all the places that children
will access them. So data privacy,
the really thorny issue of data privacy.
This is obviously such a hot
topic in the last few weeks. Um,
but interestingly the US are
way ahead of Europe on this.
I'm going back to 2012 the US have a
cup of laws explicitly stated that voice
was personally identifiable information,
much like video and images were.
And therefore you needed to have explicit
permission from the parents to collect
data. Right now, explicit,
it's very explicit.
It's like using a credit card to make a
micropurchase or having the parent put
in their email address,
email sent to parents.
The parents have to thick consent
and then you have to remind them.
But they could send like an written in
language that they can understand and um,
it was very explicit and weren't right.
Um,
both with the advent of, um, the, uh,
uh, these voice assistance
in the home, the FTC, um,
relaxed the rules only very
recently and said, okay,
we understand that these
devices are in the home.
So therefore if it replaces the voice,
replaces what they would have been typed,
it's okay to use it. Um, for
only that purpose and songs,
it's deleted immediately.
So it was great. So they, you know,
that meant in most people's minds, okay,
we're good to use it in the home.
But what was not considering was a
couple of issues is, um, you know,
what happens on the backend.
You collect data from a child, um,
is the data deleted immediately,
which meant you need to get
for a child or not child data?
Is the data to delete immediately?
Is there a data extractor for that as
the data extract used for other purposes?
What's that data used for?
So while we can somewhat say that
we're addressing some of these issues,
it has been very unclear to date
exactly what data has been collected,
exactly what, when the data has been
deleted and what's the data used for.
And that is because it's an exploding
area and the area's growing so quickly,
it's often hard for the,
the laws.
And the FTC did really struggle with
this and kind of came up very short, um,
about what to do,
what happens if you've can permission
to your child to use the device and the
dick data's been collected with the
child's friend visits the house. You know,
what happens to that data
that had been addressed. Um,
what have you just take the device out
of the box and put it here. Um, you know,
is everybody being sure that the data
has been deleted immediately and that's
really a thorny issue.
So the FTC relaxed the room.
So a lot of people now in gray water
gone. They think we were okay. We,
the public or who are put that device
in the home are unsure when the data has
been deleted. Exactly. The EU in the GDPR,
the much fear Gdpr and 20, May,
2018 have not relaxed the room.
Um,
that means that data is not allowed to
be collected without explicit permission.
So you take a device,
you put it out and put it in your home,
you plug it in a child who uses it.
Whereas the responsibility is
everybody immediately reacting,
recognizing that a child has spoken
versus an adult and we're reacting
appropriately.
So if people are got the problem here,
is that because the FTC kind of took a
bit of a back step on the blind eye for a
couple of years and
then it got sorted out.
Ma is the idea that that you would
do the same as a little bit? Um,
less clear.
One reason why I would say that is
because last year the Cayla doll was, um,
are recalled from the market in Germany
and not just what's a recalled was the,
what Cambridge was that parents should
destroy the style because the DOL is
listening to your children at all times
and sending the voice data to a company
that has links to the u s military.
Yeah. That company was nuance, which,
you know,
it's a very reputable voice technology
company around for a long time and they
have done Darpa projects.
So technically it was correct,
but who the reaction from Germany was.
So put off sets what we've seen already
in the FTC in the u s that I think it
should give us all pause to say,
how are we doing this?
How are we doing this appropriately?
And I don't think that they're going
to see a blind eye. So in that case,
so what we have to re envision how people
are using these technologies apart.
What we do is we have a voice companies
and we have solutions to bed to help
companies better comply with a
global data privacy regulations.
So this is just on the company.
I mean I can,
we can chat more about in a little while
before just just on what's happened
with the company.
We don't start back in 2013 and 2018.
We've raised a couple of
rounds of funding from um,
privately and from the EU as well.
Um,
and we've got some great coverage from
tech crunch and wires on the next Webinar
in recent months as well.
So we were 10 at the end of the year.
We're 13 as him from this month and then
we're scaling quite rapidly this year
like you know, so I can leave it
there and thank you for listening.
Thank you. Patricia. Overview.
You talked a lot of both your company
as I want to take a few minutes talking
with you. Yeah. Your,
your journey to the share,
how you've gotten to where you've
gotten to here. Um, phenomenal here.
The story 2013, um, pure
tech built in Ireland,
a scaling company, so, so well
done on that, but maybe give some,
a bit of your background.
I mean the,
the journey today wrote up the,
the start to soapbox labs.
Yeah, sure. Um,
so I qualified as a software engineer
back in 97 some while ago and I spent a
couple of years working as a software
engineer and worked on but on the signal
processing if I 2000 I went back to
college to do a phd in speech recognition
technology because, you know,
it was that, it was new.
I mean we've been doing speech to
text since the 70s properly. Um,
but it was so different what we do it,
how we do it now and the volumes we do
it with an a on the approaches are so
different than the ambition was
different. Um, but I spent time,
I started a new CD but I
spent time I had in New York,
I'm in Columbia University but then in
also in IBM research and the Yorktown
Heights research facility.
And then when I finished my phd,
I started in a bell labs,
which is now Nokia bell labs.
And I spent seven years there
kind of working on research
for them more and more.
As time went on into the commercialization
of research innovations. Um,
I'm trying to, I was always
kind of pushing for new
technologies or new research.
We should do a new products we
could bring to market. I'm saying,
um,
in some ways kind of pitching ideas and,
and value propositions.
I'm trying to get resources and funding
to fund projects within the organization,
but by 2013,
identify the fairly significant gap,
which was children's speech recognition.
But I felt like I needed
to invest time in a,
and I'm trying to figure out what the
problem was and it was something we need
to do myself.
So I,
I quit for labs to start to just
find a soapbox labs in 2013.
And was that an Aha moment or was this
one of these kind of you build up the,
see the problem and identified the gap?
How exactly did you,
did you come up with
this specific problem?
Um, it was all my experience up to
that point led me to the Aha moment.
And you want like that, you know,
I was here, I was working with,
my daughter was three at the
time, have Asian, um, you know,
downloading apps and web services and
kind of look the way I think I was trying,
you know, phonics and
getting her, you know,
read enough stuff like that could be
acutely maths apps and that kind of like,
it's fun. It's still from the reading
and stuff. And it was just, she was,
it was always multi choice.
Anything student reading and language
learning was always a little to choice
because I kind of figured out what they
have no way of assessing whether she
could get this right or not.
So she's playing these beautiful games,
they're all done.
You don't want to be a pedagogy.
It was great in the middle of that,
but they have no way of assessing.
I remember asking her, she completed
a level or whatever it was, um,
you know, I was offering you just
finish that and then, you know,
I'd ask her what to say and was,
what the word I don't know.
And I started watching what you do.
She was just gaming them cause
she got it wrong the first time.
She just knew the next time I to do the
other one and she had no clue what they
were. You know, she didn't
know what the sand she'd know.
Village to reculture wasn't even
read the sand or the word. Um,
and to my mind that meant there was, you
know, why isn't anybody doing things?
Because,
you know,
I'd been working on speech recognition
for so long at that point and I knew
where we were going without adult
speech recognition, you know,
the writing was on the wall and we think
we'd be at these voices listening stage.
Um, so it's just baffles me that
nobody had actually put anything. Nope,
not that 10 would African they have,
they just hadn't got to the same stage.
You know,
and you know,
it's why I spent quite a bit time for
trying to figure out what the problem was,
why don't not.
Um,
so it was definitely my experience
coupled with sitting with my daughter and
going Ah, right there and then realize
it was actually bigger than I thought.
Like the problem.
Okay. And in the last five years, I
mean, you spend a lot of time, uh,
working with some of the biggest
names. So I mean, Ibm and bell labs,
you're now in a startup environment. What
have you taken from, from that time, Eh,
in the corporate environment.
So as many of us here,
I were working in big companies,
we like to think where to start up a
in many ways in Google and, but what,
what have you taken and what are you
applying in your current role today that,
that you've, you've,
you've learned in your,
so we're, we're B to B, so we don't
bring products to market ourselves.
We license our technology.
So it was one of my learnings,
hobby for my bell labs days that, you
know, it's such a big ecosystem, you know,
to possibly say I was going
to do everything myself.
I went from every bit of funding it with
a raised would've gone way too thin and
I realized that to in order to
develop the technology we need it.
And I actually realized slowly over
time have bigger problem was and how
difficult a problem was that the minute
we started going to the end user and we
started going B to c,
we have to invest a huge amount of
technology in that end of it as well.
I started funding and resources. So part
of it when we were in Belarus, we still,
you know, one of the thinking
was part of the corporate things,
you don't have to do everything,
you know,
you kind of partner and you can actually
just decide and laser focus on this
problem and then find partners.
Because you know what,
that's what big companies do with partner,
where it makes sense.
But also what, what I learned
also was that how, um,
to talk to girls and to know what their
problems were and their pain points and
realize actually sometimes the left
hand doesn't know what the right hand is
doing. So you know what we've described.
Sometimes we go to big organization,
get a contact in top someone.
They might not think they have a problem
realizing they have a problem or a no,
that person is just
too busy or they don't,
they haven't put it as the prior to that.
But you might actually talk
to a different per person,
the organization and this is their pain
point and they will talk to you and then
you start engaging. So I think
sometimes people, you know,
you talked to him corporate, you get
one, they'll though their own way to,
and you think that's it and you
walk away. Um, but you know,
realizing that very big corporations,
it's just not possible to know what every
part of the organization is doing and
served as well.
Um,
and then realizing where in the
organization to try and get contacts into,
you know,
it's definitely relationship building
over the last couple of years and we kind
of use a lot of our professional contexts
over the last 20 years and to help
getting to talk to the right people.
And that's what,
okay.
Any big surprises mentioned 2013 to today.
I'm sure it's been lots of ups and
downs of the journey, but what,
what's going to surprise you most that,
that you weren't thinking before you
took the leap into starting a company?
Um, I was full sure at the start
that'd be, I'd have more competitors,
but I then had made two, three
years, four years until I went, oh,
that's why this is TRRS, you know,
all, there's people, you know,
we'll go fry bigger fish like
before they'll do this by,
but we've been very focused on the shared.
But yeah, I think two things happened.
I was surprised it took as long as it
did for the voice systems to take off.
But that's right now if
that's, there's always many
factors for that. Um, and then,
you know,
in the child speaks to you.
I definitely think people are waking up
to the fact that it's a problem today.
Again, taught that would have
happened earlier, but you
know, that's fine. You know,
we're, we're in a great position at
the moment. It's not a bad problem.
Yeah. Um, in terms of your
self, your own time, was the,
one of the things that we talk a lot
about work life balance and trying to
figure out how you prioritize. I
mean, you've got a lot on your plate,
you've got the tech side, you've got
the vision, you've got the business. Um,
how do you determine your priorities on a,
on a given week or a given month in
terms of what you specifically are doing
versus your team?
Uh,
given the opportunity from what
you've described earlier on was just,
just so vague.
I wish had said,
I
know how I do that. I don't want to be
just parked. We prioritize on the fly. Um,
you know, I mean, my job is CEO and isn't
that just changes by the day? I mean,
honestly, you know, I'd be
walking the painter, you know,
because we just moved into a new office,
you know, where I'll be, you know,
talking to legal or talking to a Canon
C or flying into San Francisco or you
know, to New York and, um, every week is
completely different and just that's it.
It is just, you know, you're
just constantly just weighing
up stuff in your head,
dynamically priorities,
what you're told was pros last week
suddenly drops because something else just
happened. Um, but just having
a good team and everybody,
I think what helps priorities is always,
you know, having the division of mind.
And one thing we've never
changed his last name.
Does he know the voice technology getting
the best possible platform that serves
until, you know, our, our, our
different verticals. Um, that,
that is a system that everybody can
use and we don't have to customer for
everybody. That all those things have
been a focal point for us. So, you know,
we have a number of different clients
and they're all looking for different
things. We actually see Noah,
um, that helps, you know,
not being afraid to say no because,
you know, just cause you want it.
If nobody else what the client wants on
thoughts, probably not a priority for us.
Like, you know, um, you know, so
we try and build something that's,
that's a useful product to as many people
as possible. And then things like that.
Like,
so always having that in mind when you're
making your party list for the week
or, yeah. Okay. Pivoting into the, um,
back into the business, you presented
a whole bunch of logos at the very,
very start, some of the biggest companies
in the world and all in this space, um,
commercialization of, of voice,
technology. You important,
where do you see five,
10 years and what's your perspective on
the revenue streams that are going to
come out of these technologies for it,
for all these companies?
I think a lot of conversation
now is about winning the home.
Um, you know, I think that's what's a
driver for most people. I mean, you know,
they're not charging for it.
Um, but you know, you know,
when you see what people are trying to do,
I think is to draw you into an ECO
system and how that you ecosystem be as
useful as possible to, um, and that's
where I think there's, you know,
it's not about the
voice technology per se,
it's about you using one device over
another, a pain for the hardware.
Or maybe maybe you do your buying there,
or maybe you're, um, you're, you're,
you're sitting your services that you
and this are like who's giving you the
best experience.
And that's where you go in what most of
these bigger companies have realizes,
Gosh, you know, you know, I'm an
apple fan. I've got an Iphone,
I've got a Mac book, I've
got, you know what I mean?
And I will probably get the home. But
if they ever fixed Eric, you know,
those types of things, um, you know,
so all those things I think
make you, um, there'd be no,
it was kind of like being in
Mcdonald's lifer, you know,
that's why I kind of see where
people are viewing the utility, uh,
and revenue streams. But that's not
to say it's not going to change. I do.
I think,
I think it's going to be case if your
product will look less for not having good
to voice technology as an interface,
you look like antiquated technology.
If you don't have good and that means
it's going to be on, you know what I mean?
There's, there's cars that are, you know,
partnering with some pretty big speech
technology companies, um, you know, to,
to bring it into,
you know,
if there's no way you're like the Tesla's
got a pretty good speech recognition
technologies go, you can't bring out a
quality product without users. Again,
you know, over time it's going to just
become more of the norm. Um, you know,
on everything you sell,
the majority of it will be done by voice.
And how has that evolution changed your
thinking on how soapbox approaching the
market over the last five years?
Things have moved very, very fast in,
in the market.
Have you had to pay a bit?
Have you had to twist to be at the change
or is your, your approach to the same?
Um, what can we started using
the word skills in the last year?
I think that's a change on a
voice device. Like so, you know,
but no,
not in some ways.
We always designed to be an underlying
technology that would serve into
education, gaming. Um, you know, we
always have the utility box they're like,
which is like things that whole
advisement talk about voice control in a
robotics, the AI or Vr, all that.
Like toys is a big one as well. Um,
what changed a lot for us is over
the years that we, you know, we put,
start putting a stronger,
a stronger focus on data
privacy and data protection and,
and what that means and we want to
be sure that we were leaving field.
Now we know,
we know how it works and we want to
make sure that we can help other people.
It can be, to be compliant to my mind was
knowing that was going to be a problem.
Um, and you know, you better hit
those things head on early on. Okay.
Maybe going to be more specific
on, on the offering. Um,
so sitting underneath tilt black
labs, there's, there's up to some Ip.
And in terms of development,
how have you gotten there in terms of
like really getting something unique and
something different that not
available America base? So the, the,
the idea is that tall, it's
the technologies, what exactly
is under the hood. Okay.
Um, I was like kind of puts it in the
bud and the talk was about the data.
I mean, you know, we use stage of the
art deep learning technologies. Um,
we have a team that's,
you know,
I think we've over eight years experience
in the team and speech recognition
technology that's actually growing. I
got, might have to Abdullah. Um, you know,
we concentrated on quality
data first. Um, you know,
I recognize that problem after my
experience in bell labs in actually it was
Google back in the early two thousands
that started a really clever of data
collection program.
These goop for one,
one that you bring in us
for advice and um, you know,
you get a free information call if you
use voice technology back in the early
two thousands. And it was actually very
effective where techs and data, um,
you know, there's good stars in
a long time before anyone else.
But my own experience,
I worked in a number of different in
the bell lab stays where love like data
versus real world data, actually an
IBM as well. What's that? You know,
you can collect all the data in the
world and build very efficient system,
but if it's not represented in a
book where you expect to use, um,
the voice technology, it won't
work. Um, and that's, you know,
all those learnings have led us to do
things in a different order though.
The people who were doing it, you know,
we were concentration on, on quality data,
understanding the problem, understanding
the application areas. Um, and then Larry,
not state of the art technology or cloud
based API and making it available and
all those things.
So there's this kind of multiple
layers of expertise from the team.
And our own experience as well, like you
know, come people who came to the we,
you know, how we do it, how we
dress, behaviors, all of that.
That's like as well as the Tysons,
the virus of data that
maybe opened up to the floor.
Questions for Tricia. Thanks
for the talk. Very interesting.
Um,
I was wondering if you could share some,
some information about a effect at a
thousand children to especially on their
behavior. Right. So with the, with the
products that are on the market now,
it's very often that all is that is
needed is a command or an order basically.
So you say like, hey, Google, do this,
but you never say please or thank you
or anything like that. So what kind of,
what kind of impact does that have on,
on the behavior of a child that
they think that that's normal. Um,
and when they ask someone else to someone,
some something else it do someone else,
like are they going to copy that
behavior as well or do they realize that
they're not talking to technology
as a parent? Um, you know,
I would always advocate you
safely as regards. It's so,
I mean it comes from the parents.
I mean there's lots as the child,
it could be rude to another human.
I think you're teach those behaviors in
some ways the fact of Alexa will do or a
Google home and do it
regardless. You know, maybe
that's a little like, you know,
a little add on or a little like opt in
that you got do she won't do it unless
you say please push that back in
Google to do, address that issue.
My question is about the product.
Is it more like Nicholas fire
for kids voice or is it um,
speech cognition including
kids classifier or four kids,
four kids voice for instances is you're
trying to predict if this kid's speaking
or his children's speaking or is it
more speech recognition including kids
trying to understand what they say?
We do both. So we recognize adult
versus child with classification.
And then there's also speed
tracking those as well.
And for the classifier. How
do you classify, how do you,
what is the threshold for being at
voices or children or adult voice?
So traditionally you know,
it's kind a well recognized problem
under the age of 12 is when you find the
voice starting to differentiate the most.
So that depends on the
client let's say or you know,
coming to Austin by what their
specification is. Would they rather,
what would they rather it happen?
It's not going to be binary,
somebody black or white.
So you're not going to be able to say
I've cut off at 13 cause you're gonna have
some 11 year olds are going to speak like
a 13 year old and 13 year olds how to
speak like 11 year olds.
So you will have that I a grayer area.
There was definitely,
yeah, you get to see it.
It's quite clear once you start going
anyway, younger friends, who can I ask?
I can receive of
off classification.
I've seen this is kid's voice or
legitimate kid's voice and for the age,
if I could share more
information about it after,
but it would very much 10 months,
that's, I don't have all the,
I think like say you're going to say,
can I recognize a four,
five year olds from an adult's,
I'll say a hundred percent accuracy if
you're going to start saying to kind of
recognize a 12 year old from an adult,
that gets harder. So it depends on it.
It's very easy to separate
the young children with
models. I'll say that for me.
Thank you.
Since you have an Alexa at home,
do you have any other voice assistant?
No,
I don't have a big fee in a
cereal on home devices and stuff.
And uh,
is it purely out of a professionally
dressed that you have it at home or do you
actually use it for,
um, queries? Yeah,
it was definitely bullied as
a research piece of equipment.
So really I think it bought it from the
u s because I wanted to have it back in
2015 or 2016 and then, um, I, you
know, I have access to a Google homes.
We've been testing that as
well. Um, I, yeah, we use it.
We definitely use it like as a,
yeah, these are old timers, alarms,
you know, play music is a big
one in our eyes. Um, yeah.
How do you spell this butts,
you know,
general knowledge just for fun sometimes,
like I think,
I think the utility can be better. I
think we haven't quite seen it. Yes,
I think it's quite limited. And then
sometimes on the, on an Amazon though,
could you actually see you're working in
somewhere like the u s where or London
where you got Uber and you've got your
deliveries and you've got all the,
you know, the way he goes,
call me an Uber. I'll see.
That's what I want to be
able to do. Like, you know,
we can't do that here in Ireland.
So I think in our were somewhat limited
because they only just released it for
Ireland. It's depends on what it's
connected to and what apps you enable.
I think we're somewhat limited here.
I've definitely seen better utility.
And from your personal experience,
which one do you find more accurate
that Alexa or the Google home?
I would say Google in the natural
language. Understanding for sure. Um,
uh, I would say you get to way too
many. I don't know what that means,
uh, on Alexa, but I think that's an
understood problem. Um, I think, you know,
and then there's problems,
flights first.
So I think both of them
have their strengths.
Has what your linkedin to
friends of what you need as well.
I think on accuracy people wouldn't do,
you never really hear one side can
be that strong with the other. Um,
I think when it comes to kids speech,
I won't say we've done our own
particular research online.
Thank you.
You took a, you talk about the speech
recognition of course, but have you ever,
or is there a lot of um, focus us on the
other side? So I mean for me it's, it's,
it's really weird to that you have this
advanced speech recognition everywhere.
But a system that asks you, especially
in this IVR system is very clunky,
still like very robotic and very,
if you want vola pastors.
So is there anything going on, especially
for kids on the how this is surf,
like this is a fun assistant and he
doesn't ask and answer in a way that he
might expect some that
more human like you know,
like maybe throwing a joke in or like
presenting it in a different way as this
completely, are these two separate
feeds us the same kind of the same
type thing with voice.
Yeah. Like those are the assistant
being more like I'm not the person then,
then just a piece of technical like,
you know, I can relate to that person.
He has some city jokes in that program
and the personality, that kind of thing.
There's nothing really on the
market that's blown us away,
but we know that's a huge amount
of companies looking at this.
I'm not a huge amount of research done
on, it's actually, funnily enough, we've,
we've looked and we've been
asked about a recently, um,
if I've thought exactly what would that
voice assistant or chop off a child,
you know what makes more sense because
the kids use different language.
They have their concepts of symptoms.
You can't use a lot of what you would use
for an adult with a child because they
won't get it and it's not appropriate.
Sometimes even the concepts can
be just too much. Like you know,
they don't get the subtleties. And then
again, it depends on the age group.
You took my four to seven are
you talking about nine to 12?
There's a lot of very little, very little.
It's been done but, but then again,
you think about the whole chat Bot,
that kind of automated system,
that natural language understanding
is still quite new for adults.
We're only getting better at it now.
What I've seen is quite a gun
law book. Kids, it will up.
We've seen a lot of people working on,
oh hi. Thanks a lot for that presentation.
Because of the nature of your company,
I guess you have collect out of access
still to a lot of data and voice samples
of little kids.
So if you could share it,
like how do you approach gathering this
data, collecting this or buying this,
getting access to it and how do you make
sure it is compliant with all of the
privacy regulations
that you just mentioned?
Yeah, so we, we just do
it ourselves. We don't,
we don't talk too much about how we do it,
but we've from the Gecko in 2013 we've
been fully compliant with Karpov and made
sure I was quite, cause I started
with company myself like that.
So I made sure I was engaged with,
you know,
privacy lawyers and
understanding this and,
and more so understanding that we didn't
really have an obligation to do it in
the beginning,
but you know,
it was one of those things I really told
was going to be an issue and it should
be an issue and it should be addressed.
So, you know, for a small company,
I don't think it's worth taking
risks on something like that.
So we've done everything ourselves. Um,
um, and I'm glad about that as well. Um,
because you know,
it actually wasn't to buy data because
there isn't anything equivalent out there
and not, and not real world
data, not tacked on a mobile
device, not on, you know,
in a real environment, not an
uncontrolled ways. And, and to my mind,
everything else was used because, you
know, again, like I said, if you get that,
that the only days you could buy it was
fairly lab like environment, um, you know,
controlled by an adult or a parents
in there making a child read something
that's not real world
stuff. So, um, we've,
we've been very careful to
do it ourselves. We've been
careful to be compliant,
um, globally. Um, and, and to that
end, that's a lot of value to us.
Like in the middle,
we can stand over what we've done.
That's a lot of five,
I guess to my part of the company.
One follow up question then, uh, do
they take into consideration the, um,
and make sure you, you, you, you collect
the samples from different countries,
different cultures,
just to avoid the cultural country buyers.
Yeah, we've dated from over
170 countries now. You know,
tens of thousands or more
than that though. Yeah. Um,
that was huge as well actually, to be
honest, because what am I, you know,
I lived in the US for quite a bit
in the drain in different areas.
And one of the things I always noticed
about is if you live in New York or a of
you drop a panel at school in New York,
I'm sure you're not going to get off
or 20% New York accents, you know,
so why just build a system with
us accents, like, you know,
and that was really key that if a
system has gone to work everywhere you,
the world's just working with that all
year, you know, you've got such, you know,
flow of people, whoever, and to be honest,
like deep learning and all
those technologies have,
the advantage is that that's allowed us
to be able to add multiple variations
and pronunciation to the system.
Whereas when I started this back two days,
we were, you'd have like,
you know, Midwestern,
you probably have a marble from Midwestern
us and you know, small brush, like,
you know,
and even even at that,
you probably have to break it out into
different dialects in that sense and
stuff like that because the systems could
cope with the variation where we can
now,
which is amazing.
Uh, thank you for the talk.
And really interesting.
I actually got interested in the
topic because of the Ad Week and uh,
talk about that as well
on the future of search.
So it had a lot of similar implications
in terms of what happens if a child is
in the room and also what does that
mean for advertising invoice? Serge,
do you have any take on the combination
of advertising in voice search in the
future and children being in the room
because there's a lot of regulations and
problems with that too.
Yeah, I think we much like I said about
the appropriateness, like, you know,
I mean dot. Um, you know,
it's probably, you know, for advertisers,
I think you don't want to waste time
advertising to children because they're
not, they're not the buyers.
So, you know what I mean?
As much as you sh you ethically need
to be able to make it an appropriate
experience for a child.
Um, you also, you know,
commercially shouldn't wasting advertising
dollars on advertising to a chance.
So I think, you know, again, the simple,
I don't try and classifiers for
different age groups as well,
is it's appropriate. You know, even
on us, no these days, you know,
those are quite strict regulations on no
regulation for by guidelines as well as
they've, what you should advertise
to children. So it was free.
You can slot in static guards, put her,
she'll be up an nod on Lego or Barbie,
but it shouldn't be an add on
something inappropriately. Um,
and I think that's just, you know,
it's a sense really as well as just,
you know what I mean?
The,
there's one side that's regulation is
going to force us all to do these things
correctly and it's by time. Um, but on
the other side there's definitely just,
just good sense of actually,
you know, you know,
as much as you target your
ads to different demographic
demographics, I think.
Yeah.
Great. One more, one more
question.
Oh, I'll take the last one. Uh, you,
people who've stopped running at five
times to get their next meetings,
I'm guessing a lot of people here will
be doing that and we've talked a lot
about the hard work to date,
uh,
the problems you're solving and things
are going after. That's at, in 10 years.
Your hope for soapbox labs for
you'll be what you'll be doing. Yeah.
We would like to share
on the air the future.
Yeah. I mean we don't, we know initially
are for the next few years anyway.
We've got a big focus on multilinguals.
Um, I think that's a huge thing.
You know what I mean? We can't
just continue to expect, you know,
it's been such a hard slog to get
anything quality out there in English,
but we've learned so much. We've
got, we've got our pipelines,
we've got our processes,
we can accelerate now.
I didn't languages and
that's what we raise.
Do you funding for actually we raised
quite considerable funding at the end of
last year, um, to take
our opera multilingual. So
that's going to be a massive,
um, you know, focus of the company. Um,
and eventually does lots of
different variations of speech,
all types of voice technology where
voice comes into it and it's kids.
That's where we'll be.
And we're already building up expertise
in a number of different areas, you know,
doing more natural language
understanding as well around children,
things like that that we think,
and we listened a lot to what our clients
were saying to us and what they want,
um, to be able to bring to
market. Like No. So you know,
as much as we will do certain
amounts of much lower limbs,
but we're listening all the time
to what they want. Um, you know,
going into too much detail that, you
know, we're responding to that. Uh,
and right now we have a great position
in the market because we have, you know,
quite an lead. Um, and because we
focus, we focus solely on that.
We haven't diversified over the
last five years on kids. Uh,
but there are so many
opportunities globally.
There's so many opportunities in this
like, so. Yeah, we'll just keep building.
Yup. Well, great space, great company.
Thank you very much for taking the
time coming in to talk to us here,
sharing your journey,
sharing the soapbox,
that journey at best wishes
for the future. I mean, uh,
I know pretty much you have
an was probably excited
about where voice is going
and where the is going.
And it's great to see an Irish company,
Indigenous Company, uh,
doing real tech work here,
but an ambition to go global as well.
So thank you very much.